AND STAY SAFE OUT THERE.
>> WE WILL KEEP FIGHTING,
THANK YOU.
AND OF VIOLENCE AND INTIMIDATION
APPARENTLY FALLS YOU TO THE BAR.
JOHNNY McKAY MADE HEADLINES
YESTERDAY AFTER SOMEONE TORCHED
HIS TRUCK BECAUSE HE DARED TO
HAVE A PRO-TRUMP STICKER ON IT.
JOHNNY, FIRST OF ALL, GOOD TO
HAVE YOU WITH US.
IS THIS LIKE A NORMAL OCCURRENCE
FOR TOP SUPPORTERS IN WASHINGTON
STATES, WHICH IS OBVIOUSLY A
VERY LIBERAL STATE, WHAT GIVES
HERE?
>> WASHINGTON IS ACTUALLY MORE
PRO-TRUMP THAN JUST ACROSS THE
RIVER IN PORTLAND, SO IT'S VERY
UNUSUAL.
>> Laura: SELECTED THE STICKER
LOOK LIKE?
>> I HAD TWO STICKERS.
THEY BOTH WERE TRUMP 2,020.
ONE SAID MAKE LIBERALS CRY AGAIN
AND THE OTHER ONE SAID IT, KEEP
AMERICA GREAT.
>> Laura: MAKE LIBERALS CRY
AGAIN IS REALLY FUNNY, AND YOU
HAVE TO GET ME ONE ALTHOUGH I
THINK I WILL PUT IT ON MY OLDER
CAR.
SO YOU CAME OUT OF THE BAR, AND
YOU LEFT THE CAR THERE BECAUSE
YOU STAYED THERE LATE, AND THEN
YOU CAME OUT THE NEXT MORNING,
WHAT HAPPENED?
>> MY WIFE WAS AT WORK AND I WAS
HOME BORED SO I WENT TO THE BAR
TO HAVE A COUPLE DRINKS AND PLAY
SOME POOL.
I WAS ONLY THERE FOR AN HOUR AND
A HALF, I HAD FOUR BEERS AND
PLAYED A COUPLE GAMES OF POOL
AND LEFT AT 10:30 P.M.
I TOOK AN UBER HOME BECAUSE I
WAS FEELING IT AND WHEN I LEFT
IN THE MORNING, IT WAS GONE.
IT WAS COMPLETELY TORCHED.
THE THING THEY DIDN'T LIKE ABOUT
IT BECAUSE THEY -- THE LADY WHO
INITIALLY CALLED 911 TOLD THE
BAR OWNER, IT SAID ON THE FRONT
DOOR, F YOU TRUMP COME ON IT.
BUT THE SCORCH BURNT THE OTHER
PART OFF AND ALL THAT WAS LEFT
WAS THE TRUMP PART.
>> Laura: I'M SURE IT WASN'T,
WE LOVE TRUMP, LET US BRING YOUR
TRUNK.
TRUCK.
I'M REALLY SORRY THAT HAPPENED
TO YOU.
YOU CAN'T PUT A BUMPER STICKER
ON YOUR CAR.
CONFUSE THEM NEXT TIME AND HAVE
LIKE, AMERICA GREAT AND THEN
LIKE, VISUALIZE WORLD PEACE OR
QUESTION AUTHORITY.
YOU HAVE TO HAVE LIBERAL
GREENPEACE STUFF AND TRUMP STUFF